See if we can get a White game. And let's
roll the cameras.  S Bertras
Angeles 1490. Let's go.
E four.
And great game.
Okay, nicely done. We
won.
Let's go again.
GG. Very good. Okay, that's gonna be a
YouTube video right there.
Uh, we're blackens 1500.
Slightly less appealing pairing, but
nonetheless okay.
Immortal game of the speedrun.
Okay. Another
Ceciliano.
And we are right at the threshold
where people   start to play more
of the open Sicilian, I would say.
Uh, still a lot of
anti Sicilians, a lot of alipins. And knight
C. Three. Bishop c four. Yeah. So we face
bishop C four again, and
we have faced this once before in the
speedrun,  but we faced it through a
slightly different move order. We faced the
bowdlar attack, knight F three, knight
C six, and then Bishop C four. The immediate
bishop C four does not really change all
that much because, well, our
response is knight C six. And frequently.
White plays night f three. Of course, White
does not have to play Night F three. White
can play Quinn H five,   um,
or Queen F three or whatnot?
And Queen h five is played. Wow.
1500 playing quinn h five. All right,
well, it is
worth knowing how to defend against this
move, because some people do get thrown
off by queen H. Quin H five here
against the Sicilian is a little bit more
serious than it is against the E uh, four e
five. So how should we continue?
Well, definitely not, ah, night F
six, not D six. We need to
defend both at the same time. And the best
way to do that is, of course, the move E
six, which you should be thinking about
anyway, the moment that White plays
bishops E four, and it would have been
possible E six here is also perfectly
fine. It's just that we wanted to keep
flexibility by developing a knight first.
But E six is a move that you should
automatically associate, uh,
as a typical response to bishop C
four because it blunts the bishop.
Obviously, bishop takes C six we can take
with the deep on and on. The next
move, what we don't need to do is play G
six. You don't need to specifically
chase the queen away. You do want to chase
the queen away, but you want to do it
while also developing your minor
pieces. So, without much
ado here, the obvious move is just Night F
six. I mean, the position I hate this
phrase, but the position really plays itself
so far. You're just getting your pieces out,
and White is already in trouble because the
queen doesn't have any, uh, super
good squares. The thing is, uh,
White needs to keep his E four pawn
protected,
and    the queen has two
squares. Well, three squares technically,
from which it can do that. It can do that
from H four. It can do that from F three
or from e two. Now, F three and E two
both walk into various tempo
moves with our knight, like queen E two, we
can play 94. Queen F three, we can
play 94. We can even play
95 and root out the
lightskirt. Bishop.
So White's kind of bitten off more than they
can chew here.
So what about queen H four? What's wrong
with queen H four? Well, we're about to find
out. Queen H four on the board    again.
Uh, in such
positions, meaning against these types
of terrible openings, you have a million
ways to play. So you shouldn't get too
bogged down here and say, well, I have to
find only the right move and I'm going to
take five minutes here and try to figure it
out. There's usually going to be two or
three moves that are approximately
equivalent in strength, all of which
give you a pretty big
advantage. So I think the most
straightforward move to me is
bishop F eight to E seven, creating an
x ray against the queen.
Now, does Bishop e seven
actually threaten any immediate
discoveries? No, but if you
think about the future after bishop E seven,
we are likely to play the move D
75. Right. And if you think that
after the trade, we will have
the possibility of playing knight F 60, E
four, and the queen there is almost trapped
on H four. So that's one option.
Another option?
Well, knight takes E four is a move
here,   but that's definitely not the most
that we can do. That kind of allows White to
bail out. If you calculate the line
94, queen e
center fork trick, white can play
bishop takes D five, and
we can't take with a pawn because it's
pinned. We're going to have to play queen
takes D five, and I really don't want to
allow a queen trade in this position that
really seems like a bailout. So
another option here is to play 94 and hit
white where it hurts on the, uh,
C two pond, which is not that easy to
defend, by the way. So after
94,   I, um, don't see a
good move for White. I I really
don't.   Um,
White might have to play a move like Bishop
back to B three, but
then already we have a move like C four.
No, we definitely should play 94. Yeah,
this is very promising and it's not a big
commitment to play 94. So the reason I
played this relatively fast and
relatively speaking, without much
calculation, is just because
I don't see a downside to this move. We can
always revert back on the next move to D
five or to bishop E seven, but we should
try to squeeze the juice out of this
position before Whites completed their
development.    Yeah. King d one.
I don't think king D one is forced. I think
there are some subtleties here.
Uh, the grand master move is actually
e five in this position. That is
not a move that most one thousands will
think of. Again, when I say that
phrase, I never mean it
condescendingly as people understand. I
never mean it to suggest that, oh, you can't
find that move, but
it's, uh, uh, usually not on the
purview of    players
in that rating range, and I'll explain it
after the game. King D one on the board.
So order of operations
is pretty important here. I can
see two candidate moves in this
position.     Um,   the
first is bishop B seven, as before,
and D five, as
before. So   it's
important whenever you make a move like
94, anytime a piece leaves the square,
you have to consider the pros and cons.
Well, the pro is obvious. This night is
pretty sexy on D four. But what's the
con? Well, the con is that we have
allowed potentially, the move e
five. Right. And the move e five can be a
little bit annoying because it clamps down a
little bit on our center. And if
white plays e five, if we think about a
bishop e seven, e five, we
will move our knight, let's say, to D five,
and the queen can slide over to e four,
and we've sort of let the queen out
of our grasp a little bit. So, on
account of that line, I prefer
to start with D five here while
we still can. And after Ed,
we chase the bishop way, and then we play
bishop e seven. This is
borderline winning already for black. I
just feel like white's not
developed, and we keep hitting him and
it's it's just not going to be pleasant.
So hopefully
that logic made sense.
Um, again, bishop e seven allows the move
e five. Is that is it the end of
the world? No. But is it much more
accurate to start with D five?
Absolutely.     If white plays
e five here, if White
played e five here, we would have just taken
the bishop. And after pawn
takes night, we just take the pond. We're up
a pawn there. I mean, that's just a free
pawn. So e takes d
five. Obviously, we take with the pawn
and we open up the center, which is a nice
bonus given that we're ahead in development.
I honestly can't believe we're facing this
line. This is pretty crazy.
Uh, but we've had a couple
of games like this where we're
almost winning out of the opening, but we
have to handle things very carefully, very
precisely.   So
what's hilarious is that apart
from bishop e seven, which I think
we're going to end up playing, there is a
funny move that a lot of people wouldn't
consider because it allows a queen trade.
But remember that
concrete considerations always
trump general reasoning. So the
general reasoning would seem to suggest
that whenever you have an initiative quite
like this, you shouldn't trade queens. But
we can consider the move knights to e four,
and if you calculate the line queen takes
queen, king takes queen. You have knights on
e four and D four, which is a very powerful
arrangement,  uh, because they, they make
contact with the C two and F two pawns and
so white can only defend one of them
at a time.
White can't play king D one to e one because
he blunders C two. So after
94, queen takes it, king takes it. Knight
h three very importantly also
fails to bishop takes H
three. That's a byproduct of us playing D
five early. The LightSquared bishop has
opened up.    But
there is a but here. And if we play 94,
we'll probably win the game really quickly.
But I'm trying to play principal chess, so
let's calculate this more carefully. 94
queen takes D, king takes D eight.   What
we need to be careful about in that scenario
is a situation where white
essentially gets two minor pieces for
a rook. So in that position, white
can try the move c two, C three.
And I always say this, if you're watching on
YouTube and you're having a hard time
visualizing, you can either wait until after
the game or you can set up a
board and make the moves as I say them.
94 queen takes the king takes date
C three. So what's our move in that
position? Well, obviously, knight takes F
two, check.  The king slides over to E one
and that's a critical position. In
that position.   Taking the
rook I think would actually be a
mistake,   right? Because then
White will take one of the knights
and then the other knight is
likely going to be trapped and eventually
won and white is going to get two minors for
a rook. So in that position, what's the
correct move? There's a very important
resource after C three, without
which we wouldn't go for the
line   and Blarvo. Got it.
93, check. So once again,
94 queen takes the eight, king takes the
eight. C three.   Knight
takes pawn. Check. King E one, knight
back to D three with check,
forcing the king over to D one
and then the bishop comes out to G four
and that's essentially checkmate. White just
has to give up all his pieces to avoid mate.
So on the basis of that line,
I think we are safe to play
knight to e four. We don't even need bishop
E seven. We just directly go for
white's throw and we're going to win
material here.    Um,
and it's a cool line and I'll show it after
the game. And of course, bishop E seven I
think is also winning and maybe even better.
According to the engine, the engine
sometimes doesn't even go for the material
here, if that makes sense. The engine just
says, hey, I'm going for checkmate.
I want the queens on the board. Bishop E
seven and 94 looks totally crushing,
maybe what I would have played in the
classical game, but  um,   we're fine with
an extra rook. And we have an extra rook
here. Our opponent also might just resign,
which is this has been a really
underwhelming game, to be honest.
Sometimes people on YouTube say
that I seem to encounter like, very
weak opponents or people who play much worse
than their rating. And sometimes I do see
a grain of truth in that. Like, I
haven't seen a 1500 play like this
in a long time. We literally have done
nothing at all.   We just
brought our pieces out. That's
a free rook. Now,
of course, there is a possibility that
the Night is not going to get out. There is
a, um, distinct possibility that if White
handles this correctly, they're
going to ultimately trap our
knight in the corner. Big deal. We're going
to give up the Night for a pawn we're going
to be up a full exchange and a pawn in an
endgame that's still winning. But we're not
even there yet. We're also threatening
the other pawn on C two. And White
still can't defend that pawn easily because
if the king slides back to D one, r knight
moves back to F two.
So, yeah, our opponent just
resigns.   Yeah, one thing we know is that
our opponent did not use engine assistance.
So I already smelled a rat after Queen H
five.   Yeah already White is much
worse     for
context it's like -1.5 already
this is the consequence of bringing your
queen out like this and this is selling now
a funny story. Hikaru Nakamura,
you might remember this. Some of the old
timers who are watching this might remember
this. Hikaro had a phase
where he played Queen H Five in a
couple of classical games, like actual
OTB games. He was about 2600. This was maybe
2005, and
I think he even won one of them. He lost a
couple. But what's hilarious is he even
played Queen H Five against Andre Volakit
in Ukrainian GM in this
position against the Sicilian and here. It's
a really terrible move because Black
can just go night to F six. I think this is
considered best
against D five. It's
playable here. You give up the CPA for
the Epon and Black gets a big initiative.
Queen E Black already has better
control of the center and a nice night on E
four. This is already an edge for
Black. Okay, you can analyze this with an
engine if you'd like. It's even worse in
this position because we just go E six. And
now both of the pieces look really
stupid.
Um, a three is another weird move.
Of course, White should desperately start
getting his or her pieces out with night F
three.   But still we
can go night F six
and then D five. And
we're basically just steamrolling white
takes takes Bishop B five, bishop B
seven.   What's hilarious
is bishop E Seven is one move. The
engine even likes the check on E seven
to force the king to move
and then just back to D eight, and
then Bishop E seven. And we've gotten the
King essentially uncastled.
So there's a million things that Black can
do here. Um, I'll leave you to explore this
on your own. Let's quickly go through the
game. A three night f six. Queen h
four. So, as I was mentioning, if the
Queen slides back to E two, we have the move
Knight to D four. And in order
to keep both of these ponds protected, white
has to make this awkward move.
Uh, and then we play D Five.
And to make things even worse than that, if
the Bishop slides back, we have Bishop F
five winning on the spot.
So I guess White has to go
check.    And then we
would definitely eliminate that Bishop
and get our own Bishop out. And I'm
not even talking about Queen Takes B seven.
Just look at our development advantage in
this position.   We're going to Castle and
go rookie a check and just murder White in
the center.   So these things
don't even really need to be analyzed.
They're pretty self evident.     Queen.
Uh,   back to D one. Blunders
z four. And finally
Queen. Back to f three. Again allows
94. This is a transposition
after Queen D line that we were just
looking at. No, this is just
horrendous. And Queen H 494
is similarly bad. Now, a lot of
you guys were asking, why not Bishop D
Three? And I think this is the best
move there is. Also bishop to B.
Three.   And what's funny
is that I thought we would go C Four, but I
think C four is actually not the best
thing that Black can do. I think the best
thing that Black can do is just to
go D Five and continue
normally. Can anybody tell me, uh, A, uh,
defensive resource here for White? That's
kind of cool, and I think it holds on.
Black is winning after this move. I just
checked with the engine, but there is a move
E five opening up an attack on the night,
not C three. I know some of you are thinking
this, but now the Knight can take the Bishop
and we win the other Bishop. So it's not C
three, it's E five.   And if
Black takes on B three, this might look very
good to you at first, but
this bond is not that scary. And White plays
night C three, and perhaps the worst is even
behind him.
But here
we would go D five. Bishop did D three,
I think, is the best that White can do
here.     But, um,
here we can do a couple
of things. I like to move D five.
I was mentioning Bishop E seven
during the game. I like to move D five. And
the funny thing here is that White can go E
five and force a Queen trade. But again,
one takeaway from this game is that
just because you have a development
advantage doesn't mean that you should
automatically rule out a Queen trade. And
here, White simply loses
the E five pond, because if
White defends it, we have C four
winning on the spot. If the
Bishop moves,   you, uh,
drop C two. If you go 92,
who can spot Black's next move?
This is actually very pretty concept, black
to play and win.
Simple but deadly.
Knight c six just back. Yeah. The bishop
is trapped. The bishop is trapped.
Bishop is
trapped.    Funny line,
you don't need no bishop. C five is bad
because then the night takes the night and
the Bishop has a pathway back. You actually
need to move the night away. You need to
keep the knight on E two.
Um, and if White plays
C three, then of course, you sink your
teeth into the B three square. And we're not
talking about this light loses all of his
pieces. So,    of course,
White should not allow this.
White should play knight to e two
immediately, to smoke this night out of D
four. But we play 95 and
before recapture, we could even take the
Bishop first and ruin the structure.
Look at this. It's just garbo,
total garbo.
So, all of these lines are
tremendously one sided. Our opponent went
king D one, we go D five.
And, uh, well, the rest
is history. 94 is the top move. Yeah,
this is best. This is minus seven. Bishop
B seven is a mere minus
five. And the reason it's minus
five is because White has the move F three.
This is an idea that you've seen the Scandi,
by the way, for Black,
this idea of going F three or C
six in the scandi, if
you're familiar with it,
black frequently plays C six and drags the
Queen back. So just remember this. When the
Queen is on a ah five or H five, there's
this concept of pushing the Bishop spawn
forward and dragging the Queen all the way
back. And here, this saves White's
life for now. For now, because, like, if you
go 94 94, the Queen
can move back to E one, and White as
holding on for dear life.
Um, but 94 is is winning on the
spot, and there's just no defense here. The
best move, according to the engine, is king
E one, which tells you everything you need
to know about this position.
Yeah. Okay, resign time. It's
over.    Why can't
White just take the knight asks, can't make
money? Uh, well, the knight is defended.
The knight is defended by the D five one.
Fisher SAB asks,
what if 94 queen F four? Well, now we go
bishop D six. I'm very curious, actually.
Wait, no, here.
Oh, you know what we
should do here?   We should go
Queen F six. This is a
sexy move, queen F six. Now we
force the Queen trade
and we just play GF. And it's the same
position. Who cares about the slight
deficiency and structure? It's the same
concept. Queen f six is such a nice
move, just insisting on the queen
trade. The engine even proposes bishop
g four. Check. Typical idea,
but this is a little messy. Uh, f
three.   It's a little Leonel.
Knight f two. Check. King e one.
Oh, but you have the second
fork as well, so, uh, this is also totally
winning.  Yeah. No,
this is the definition of one sided.
And the game is already over.
So pretty underwhelming game. But a good
illustration of exactly what happens when
you just shamelessly violate
all opening principles at once.
Uh,   if you play sound
chess and you don't let your opponent get
away with it, the game will not last long.